[Música]
hola soy maría clara calle bienvenidos a
este espacio para hablar de medio
ambiente en france 24 y hoy hablaremos
de uno de los proyectos más criticados
del presidente de méxico andrés manuel
lópez obrador se trata de el tren maya
este es uno de los planes bandera de su
administración pues propone construir
más de 1500 kilómetros de ferrocarril en
cinco estados del sureste que
tradicionalmente han sido de los menos
desarrollados del país estos son chiapas
tabasco campeche yucatán y quintana roo
pero la zona donde se hará la
construcción coincide con la selva maya
mexicana que hace parte del segundo
bosque tropical húmedo más extenso de
mesoamérica las críticas se concentran
especialmente en el tramo 5 del tren
maya por los daños ambientales que
podría causar y es que las autoridades
federales han modificado el proyecto
original y se adentran en la selva cada
vez más inicialmente en ese sector el
tren sería elevado pero luego lo
cambiaron para que pasara a ras de piso
y también modificaron la ruta para poder
acelerar las obras
con la fecha de entrega y es que el
presidente lópez obrador dijo que llueva
truene o relampagueé inaugurarán el tren
maya a finales del 2023 cuando lanzó la
obra en 2018
andrés manuel lópez obrador prometió que
no se iba a tirar ni un solo árbol con
el ferrocarril pero greenpeace denuncia
que la tala avanza a pasos agigantados y
por eso le exigen al presidente que
frene el proyecto hasta que las
autoridades no presenten un estudio de
impacto ambiental aleira lara directora
de campañas de esta ong en méxico nos
explicó aquí en france 24 que está
ocurriendo en la selva maya de los 121
kilómetros que se han planteado
para este proyecto de construcción van
aproximadamente
30 kilómetros con 60 metros de ancho que
han empezado a deforestar y esto repito
además a pesar de no cumplir con la
presentación y aprobación de la
manifestación de impacto ambiental que
la semarnat tiene que hacer
el gobierno mexicano se defiende ante
los señalamientos de deforestación
diciendo que no están talando sino que
han reubicado más de 20.000 árboles que
estaban en la carretera que comunica a
cancún con tulum sin embargo greenpeace
denuncia que no es el único problema
según la organización el tren maya pasa
por ocho sistemas de ríos subterráneos
que podrían afectar a especies que están
en peligro de extinción también afirman
que la obra interrumpe los corredores de
animales como el jaguar
aleira lara precisa que los impactos
negativos se podrían sentir hasta en los
arrecifes del mar caribe en lugares tan
emblemáticos como playa del carmen
en este área identificamos que hay
especies catalogadas dentro de la norma
059 que tienen alguna categoría de
riesgo
en el caso de las especies que habitan
las cuevas los ríos subterráneos
pues hay dos especies en peligro de
extinción dos especies de peces ciegos
estarían corriendo riesgo el proyecto
pretende pasar encima este
importantísimo sistema de ríos
subterráneos
con construcción de pilotes e
infraestructura que estará dañando
el manto freático sabemos que se ha ido
moviendo el proyecto río arriba es decir
se ha ido internando en la selva este es
el cuarto trazo que se hace y bueno las
repercusiones de esto no se quedarán ahí
todo lo que suceda en este área irá a
derivar al mar caribe entonces la
contaminación que ocurra ahí por las
obras estará también impactando hacia
hacia la costa estas cuevas inundadas
estos ríos y cenotes son refugio de
especies en peligro de extinción como el
jaguar también son su fuente de afa
abastecimiento entonces estaríamos
afectando también estas zonas súper
relevantes para
especies por estas afectaciones
ambientales es que greenpeace lideró una
protesta en las obras del tren maya
cerca de la playa del carmen y es que la
organización denunció que a pesar de que
el plan inicial era que la megaobra
utilizará las vías férreas que ya
existían el cambio de planes hizo que se
adentrarán en la selva aleira lara nos
contó para que hicieron la manifiestas y
hace un llamado a respaldar las voces de
alerta para que el gobierno federal
proteja a la flora ya la fauna durante
la construcción del tren maya 11
activistas de greenpeace estuvimos en un
trazo de este tramo número cinco
activistas inmovilizaron maquinaria para
impedir operaciones y llamar al
presidente de la republica a replantear
su decisión a cancelar las obras en
tanto no se tengan evaluaciones de
impacto ambiental y se considere este
área como inviable para el tren maya hay
alternativas que se han planteado por la
ciudadanía por los habitantes de la
región expertas expertos que implican
pasar por el derecho de vía con un tren
ligero si la intención realmente es la
movilidad de las personas es mantén la
ciudad que se sume a la campaña para
frenar inmediatamente estas operaciones
y en nuestro sitio de internet
greenpeace punto por punto mx ahí
tenemos
una petición que va dirigida a la
presencia de la república para que la
gente se sume y protejamos uno de los
sitios más importantes para la
conservación de la biodiversidad de las
y los mexicanos hasta aquí esta crónica
de medio ambiente recuerda que pueden
consultar esta y todas nuestras
emisiones en france24 punto com y
también en nuestro canal de youtube nos
vemos el próximo martes para más
información ambiental
[Música]